you anyone who uses valet services of
course you think your car is safe but
one taurus reached out to us at 8 news
now to warn others about her car being
stolen from a strip property victoria
saha joins us live from the paris hotel
victoria has more
yeah certainly not the way you want to
end your las vegas trip this woman says
she handed the valet her car and her
keys over at the paris hotel right
behind me here and when she went back
the next day she was told someone
already checked her car out
jennifer marcacho and her husband were
looking forward to their weekend in las
vegas the couple checked into the paris
hotel friday evening and handed their
keys over to the valet he said
i'll take care of it just like it's mine
the next day she went back to the valet
only to find out her range rover was not
on the property she goes well
according to this ticket the car was
checked out last night i said i'm sorry
what markeicho was told someone checked
her car out at 11 13 p.m the same night
she checked in you know anyone just can
go to the kiosk and show a ticket and i
said
so your kiosks
have a little bit of flaw in them then
you're telling me so you guys don't ask
for id you don't ask for anything police
were called and an app was able to track
her car by boulder casino the license
plate was already replaced with a fake
one so what are your rights once you
hand over your keys to a valet we asked
attorney eric blank they are now taking
possession of that and they are now
responsible for the vehicles so your
rights would be to expect your vehicle
back in the condition that you gave it
to them at the time when you released it
to the valet as for markeisha's car
there was no damage but her personal
documents and keys to her house were
gone i just wish that something can be
done
you know so this doesn't happen to
anybody else because i would hate for
them to live the nightmare
the attorney says it's always a good
idea to have a tracking system in your
car as for the people who could have
taken marquette's car police told her
there wouldn't be any arrests since the
car wasn't involved in any crime we also
reached out to caesars to get a clear
picture of what their protocols are
regarding the valet system but we
haven't heard back yet reporting from
the strip tonight victoria saha live
local now